una sentencia histórica luego de 21 años
de lucha la corte interamericana de
derechos humanos declaró al estado
colombiano responsable del secuestro y
los actos de tortura a los que fue
sometida la periodista colombiana jineth
bedoya lima el 18 de octubre de 2021
pasa a la historia como el día en que
una lucha que empezó por un crimen
individual llevó a la reivindicación de
derechos de miles de mujeres víctimas de
violencia sexual y de mujeres
periodistas que dejan parte de la vida
en su oficio pero ella fue secuestrada y
violentada por paramilitares el 25 de
mayo del 2000 mientras esperaba la
confirmación de una entrevista a las
afueras de la prisión modelo en la
capital bogotá la periodista denunció al
estado por no garantizar su protección
pese a conocer las amenazas ahora el
organismo le da la razón la corte
interamericana de derechos humanos se
encontró al estado de colombia
responsable internacionalmente por la
violación de los derechos en la
integridad personal libertad personal
honra dignidad y libertad de expresión
la corte advirtió la existencia de
indicios graves precisos y concordantes
de la participación estatal en los
referidos hechos por su parte el
presidente colombiano iván duque que
acatará la decisión una vez más el
estado colombiano rechaza toda agresión
física y psicológica contra las mujeres
quien el bedoya jamás debió ser
secuestrado y torturada la sentencia de
la corte internacional de derechos
humanos se cumplirá en su totalidad como
siempre colombia lo ha hecho durante dos
décadas bedoya persistió en la búsqueda
de justicia este fallo es también la
hoja de ruta para la protección de las
mujeres periodistas que enfrentan
violencia sexual en el marco de los
conflictos armados